alarcon bonsoir
bonsoir merci d'avoir choisi tout le
monde en parle pour vous exprimer le 22
novembre 2001 l'écurie de formule un
proche grand prix été mise en
redressement judiciaire pour des dettes
estimées à 35 millions d'euros le 28
janvier 2002 faute d'avoir pu trouver
une solution la liquidation judiciaire a
été prononcée
et hier vendredi 8 février 2002 lusine
de guyancourt étaient fermés laventure
aura duré cinq ans presque jour pour
jour alain prost vous allez nous
expliquer vous allez vous expliquer
le 28 janvier après la prononciation de
la liquidation judiciaire par le
tribunal de commerce de versailles vous
avez quitté la salle pour aller dans une
pièce adjacente pour informer en premier
et en audio conférence les salariés de
votre entreprise de guyancourt puis vous
les avez rejoint sur place
et puis cette semaine vous avez fermé
l'usiné j'imagine à la preuve que votre
première préoccupation aujourd'hui c'est
les 195 personnes qui se retrouvent sur
le carreau
oui aujourd'hui comme comme pratiquement
depuis depuis quatre ans la première
préoccupation ça a été pour eux les
négociations d'ailleurs qui ont eu lieu
avec certains repreneurs ou
investisseurs potentiels on était
toujours dans le cadre de 2,2 de 10
rebonds même si je suis pas là il faut
absolument sauver l'équipe ne serait ce
que pour eux de toute façon si cette
équipe avait durer et perdurer on aurait
vu que les résultats aurait été de toute
façon deux meilleurs puisque tout le
travail qui a été accompli depuis quatre
ans faut bien que ça porte ses fruits un
jour par les conséquences de cette
décision du tribunal de commerce c'est
que dans les semaines qui viennent votre
écurie sera mise aux enchères vous
possédez encore 51 3% du capital il y
aura pas de bleus à melbourne le 3 mars
et pourtant vous avez déjà acquittée 296
1000 euros de droit d'inscription pour
la saison 2002 qui sont pas
remboursables en fait on est en train de
compléter leur offre ici ça peut
peut-être s'arranger parce que c'est
c'est la première fois que cette
situation existe en formule 1 pourrait
compter sur la redistribution des droits
télés 10 ans de 15 millions d'euros non
ils sont là que si on performe c'est
dire si on est dès le premier grand prix
à melbourne donc donc le pactole de 15
milliards d'euros sera partagée entre
les différentes écuries restantes quoi
exactement d'où leur empressement de
nous et des
solutions alors voilà on va parler
maintenant de l'histoire de l'écurie
prost grand prix des causes de cette
situation alors alain prost et bientôt
47 ans vous êtes né en 1955 à lorette
dans la loire enfance à saint chamond le
pays d'antoine pinay votre père et votre
mère travailler ensemble dans la
confection de meubles et des parties
métalliques pour des chaises et des
tables votre mère est d'origine
arménienne sa famille est arrivé en
france en 1920
vous vérité quoi d'elle
je pense de cette ténacité
eh ouais en fin de compte on se laisse
jamais abattre même si de temps en temps
sur la figure on va il ya des traits
mais j'ai au fond deux enfants nous même
je pense qu'on est on est vraiment des
battants donc ces deux sont des gens qui
ont vécu une manière incroyable mâcon à
grand mère me racontait le génocide
arménien hak elle a vécu vraiment avec
des histoires mais absolument rien dre
semblables je pense que vous pouvez être
que que dure d'un côté mais en même
temps avec une femme beaucoup de
tendresse beaucoup d'émotion quand par
rapport par rapport aux gens mais il ya
une grosse différence c'est que ces
gens-là c'est entre ce qu'ils montrent
ce qu'ils ont à l'intérieur alors vous
voulez d'abord devenir footballeur
professionnel
et puis le 10 mai 1970 date importante
dans la vie d'alain prost vous assister
au grand prix de monaco que vous
gagnerez 14 ans plus tard en 1984 une
étoile est née
199 grands prix cinquante et une
victoires quatre fois champion du monde
et en 93 l'année de votre quatrième
titre de champion du monde vous annoncez
votre départ définitif pourquoi avoir
pris cette décision à ce jour là dont 93
je me suis pas sentie très à l'aise
d'autres dans le milieu il n'y avait pas
pas dans le milieu mais il y avait
quelques
quelques relations un peu un peu
difficile dirait dans le pendant la
saison et
qui m'ont fait penser qu'il me fallait
vraiment mieux finir sur un tir de
championnat alors que j'avais un contrat
encore pour l'année d'après avec woods
alors en 97 vous racheter l'écurie de
ligier fondé en 1976 en signant trois
ans de fourniture de moteurs avec
peugeot et vous avez déclaré à l'époque
nous visons le titre mondial dans trois
ans oui ça c'est vraiment un c'est pas
ma phrase je voudrais vraiment
honnêtement c'est en afrique parce que
tout le business plan qu'on avait fait
c'était minimum 5 ans minimum 5 ans pour
avoir une peau in une écurie de formule
compétitive on parlait même pas de
chanter du monde d'où ça sort les trois
qui s'est passé c'est qu'on avait un
deal de cinq ans avec peugeot qui était
réduit à trois ans deux jours avant
l'annoncé parce que il ya eu des
tiraillements j'irai en interne de kid
qui avait rien à voir avec moi et il
fallait absolument présenter quelque
chose justement de présentable et la
seule chose de présentable si on a un
contrat de trois ans c'est bien de dire
qu'on va être champion du monde et donc
je me rappelle très très bien je saurai
sortie de la grande armée avec hugues de
chaunac et je lui ai dit tu vois
je pense que ça va être beaucoup plus
difficile que puisque dès le début vous
savez que ça va être très dur vous savez
c'est très difficile d'être avec un
grand constructeur donc soit c'est pour
ça je pense qu'il faut être économe en
eau selon le constructeur à la limite il
faut que ce soit lui le moteur
m'exprimer ainsi alors que là j'ai été
moi j'avais mis le nom prost que je ne
voulais pas mettre d'ailleurs au départ
parce que je voulais plus un nom basé
calquer un peu sur la halle sur le nom
france pour que tout le monde a une
sorte d' appartenance à cette équipe
alors j'ai bel nom proche d'un côté et
puis la pression du constructeur et qui
en fin de compte sur de terre en termes
de communication fait ce qu'il veut
alors vous vous êtes mis 22 millions
d'euros dans la sphère au départ vous
avez perdu
mais c'est pas très grave c'est grave
mais henri thébault mieux quand il ya un
échec comme ça
partir en ayant perdu de l'argent je
tenais c'est pas plus mal parce qu'on
part les mains propres alors mais c'est
une idée à qui de vous demander de faire
sa guide rue qui était ministre des
sports à l'époque vous a poussé un peu
reprendre l'écurie ligier parce que on
connaît on va rentrer la norme que les
liens de françois mitterrand avec ligier
séguy truqués qui m'a approché parce
qu'il y avait déjà beaucoup de
discussions et moi j'étais chez mercedes
à l'époque j'étais vraiment très heureux
cc c'est venu à partir du grand prix de
france et puis bon c'est vu
les jeunes et ensemble à paris j'ai dit
que j'étais pas intéressé donc ils ont
beaucoup insisté est bon il n'y a qu'une
chose qui pourrait me faire changer
d'avis sexy un constructeur il faudrait
qu'ils soient français parce qu'ils ne
sert à rien de ne pas avoir au moins une
écurie française avec le coeur de la
voiture française donc le moteur et avec
un budget minimum 500 millions sur cinq
ans et on l'avait pas fait parce qu'ils
avaient pas justement cette stabilité
qu'il faut absolument avoir un budget
important alors le bilan sportif de
prose grand prix c83 grand prix aucune
victoire aucune pole position un échec
non l'échec c'est d'arrêter le chèque
c'est d'arrêter et l'échec c'est d'avoir
eu une image
terne une image souvent controversées ça
c'est un échec enfin le fait de dire on
n'a pas gagné on n'a pas fait de
ne pas marquer une victoire n'est pas
champion du monde ça c'est pas un échec
pour les raisons que leur expliquer tout
à l'heure c'est il ya une chose quand
même que je voudrais dire qu'on ne gagne
pas souvent on a commencé en 97 c'est
vrai qu'il y ait en formule 1 vous
saviez des cibles c'est comme dans la
vie et puis bon les constructeurs sont
arrivés tout de suite après deux trois
ans après en masse montfort d'art
achetées
stewart après toyota honda honda renault
qui a racheté benetton nous on est
restés un peu un peu tout seul ces gens
là à chaque fois qu'ils annoncent
quelque chose qu'est ce qu'ils annoncent
aujourd'hui qu'ils vont être
éventuellement champion du monde qu'il
en faut au minimum cinq ans de l'état
ils disent il faut dix ans numéro un
mondial ils ont dépensé 600 millions
d'euros avant de commencer de courir
ouais pourquoi nous on ne reproche mais
on peut pas accepter que qu'il faut du
temps sur l'équipe qui a très peu de
moyens et qu'on accepte tout à fait que
toyota rôle on dise il nous faudra cinq
ans pour gagner ouais je n'arrive pas à
comprendre ça si je comprends mais je
vous avais peur de comprendre alors on
va parler un petit peu aussi de ce qui
vous a été reprochée parce qu'on a dit
que finalement l'arrogance et l'orgueil
qui étaient des qualités pour s'imposer
sur un circuit c'était un handicap pour
manager d'entreprise arnoux a déclaré
n'est pas jean todt qui veut
pescarolo a déclaré un grand champion
n'est pas forcément un bon patron
allez-y vous a critiqué aussi de mon
alors le fait d'avoir fait des erreurs
dont l'arrogance sincèrement si je suis
arrogant de temps en temps c'est avec
certains journalistes ou certains
journalistes qui ont une méthode une
méthode que je ne peux pas accepter dans
sas a vraiment je reconnais l'arrogance
par exemple avec mon équipe certainement
pas trop de personnes peut dire
aujourd'hui dans mon équipe de taroudant
après quand vous parlez de trois anciens
pilotes il ya eu des déclarations
notamment de jean autrement plus
qualifier autrement plus connu autrement
plus célèbres notamment des présidents
de groupes autonomie qui ont pas fait ce
genre de déclarations parce qu'elle
qu'on parle pas beaucoup de la deûle à
des problèmes économiques qui les
difficultés chercher de trouver des
sponsors à toutes les équipes mais si on
va chercher en france des gens comme toi
comme henri pescarolo monde comme
philippe arnould arnould sais bien qu'il
ya une volonté de fer man volonté de
nuire justement vous dites on n'aura
rien pardonné vous avez parlé de
lynchage total et vous portez une
accusations assez graves ou dit je
n'avais pas 100 millions de francs de
budget publicitaire a donné aux médias
et dès lors je n'y avait aucun pouvoir
sur que donc vous sous-entendez que
quand une une société peut donner des
budgets publicitaires à des journaux
même pour des voitures de tourisme
finalement on traite mieux leur écurie
vous savez très bien que c'est des
centaines et centaines de millions de
francs que ces gens-là dépense chaque
année entre les journaux et les ailes et
la télévision donc de toute façon vous
n'avez pas de vous n'aviez pas ce
pouvoir là en tous les cas on n'a pas de
pouvoir et on peut pas lutter contre ça
alors une donne importante ça a été
quand même l'échec du partenariat avec
peugeot
vous dites qu'ils ont pas assez dépensé
et à un moment vous avez d'ailleurs
pensé pour cela plus simple pour eux
finalement que l'écurie s'appelle
peugeot tout simplement et qui rentre au
capital
dès le début j'ai essayé d'inciter
beaucoup parce que je voyais très très
bien qu'il n'y avait pas une application
j'étais extrêmement déçus qu'ils aient
pris tout de suite après notre notre
accord le chemin du rallye dans la
mesure où bien entendu
bon ils ont une culture rallye donc ça
aurait été beaucoup plus facile de
gagner et puis bon dès qu'ils ont pris
la voir alice a été au détriment des
rats de la formule 1 et nous ce qu'on
recherchait c'est de cette stabilité
donc voyez très bien qu'on pouvait pas
en avoir et notre meilleure année face
qui aurait dû être notre meilleure année
c'était normalement la saison 2000 et on
a eu un échec incroyable on a cassé 57
moteur qui est pas un horaire du monde
donc on est
robert wood automne on a pas mal comme
ça mais bon c'est ça nous a coûté
vraiment très cher et en 99 en 99 on a
on avait
signe un accord pour se séparer est en
avance ce que je voyais très bien que
cette saison 2000 à être une une
catastrophe et on avait fait un accord
pour aller acheter justement notre
client chez renault alors justement
problème avec peugeot renault préfère
lancer sa propre écurie et ironie du
sort le lancement du retour de renault
en formule 1 était annoncée pratiquement
le même jour
que votre retrait donc c'était un petit
peu petit peu dur j'imagine pour vous
aurez c'est dur mais bon ce qui était
dur c'était le 2 ans avant de ne pas
avoir pu moi j'aurais beaucoup aimé
concrétiser cet accord avec renault
devrait proposer toutes sortes de
partenariats possibles même le rachat
bien entendu total de l'équipe je reste
complètement persuadés ça c'est quand
même important parce que si j'ai fait
aussi dans ce pays ce projet c'est pas
simplement pour avoir un jour une équipe
de f1 c'est parce que je pensais qu'on
pourrait gagner avec un constructeur
mais je reste persuadé qu'en france on a
une on a des gentils mots incroyables
seule chose qu'il faut c'est du temps
d'instabilité parce qu'ils ont ils ont
énormément de talent je reste persuadé
que renault aurait à mon avis mieux fait
dans le futur de reprendre cette équipe
et de l'argent tendu de la lgv est
blonde et la développer évidemment vous
n'êtes pas eu de stabilité parce que
d'abord le président de peugeot a changé
un donc ce n'était pas son histoire à
lui c'était l'histoire de son
prédécesseur nouvelle majorité à
l'assemblée nationale aussi c'est vrai
que guide rue le type que vous aurez à
mener la demande a été plus là et puis
les 35 heures c'est vrai que les écuries
anglo saxon elles ont le double de gens
pour la même masse salariale tout ça ça
fait partie d'un ensemble c'est vrai
c'est à dire que quand on fait ce projet
on dit bon on sait qu'on prend un risque
de le faire en france et quand même eu
trois ou quatre équipes qui ont quand
même dû arrêter
qui ont été liquidés dans les équipes de
formule 1 dans l'es10 quinzaine d'années
donc on sait que c'est pas facile à
partir du moment où il ya une synergie
où il ya quand même une volonté
politique il ya un constructeur
automobile moi je me suis dit là c'est
le moment de le faire je pense qu'on va
apprécier le rouleau compresseur
malheureusement c'est vrai que la
dissolution de l'assemblée nous a fait
mal dans la mesure où il ya eu en même
temps un déménagement de magny cours et
quand même un fief socialiste donc j'ai
eu tous les problèmes possibles le
comité décentralisation du management
d'euros voilà vous était aussi victime
des grands constructeurs qui veulent
éliminer ce qu'on appelle les garagistes
quoi maintenant cellectis indépendants
comme ça ça fait plutôt partie du
paysage victime du crack de la nouvelle
économie puisque yahoo était prêt à
mettre 100 millions de dollars dans
votre affaire bon qui doit seul coup la
nouvelle économie s'est un peu écroulé
victime du 11-septembre
puisque la famille saoudienne al walid
était prête aussi à vous aider enfin
voilà quoi c'est vrai que vous avez joué
un petit peu de malchance que ça va plus
on a eu énormément de mal chance mais
met vraiment en m dans cette situation
je reste toujours sur ma doctrine qui
dit que la malchance on la tire ouais et
il fallait qu'on trouve des solutions
peut-être avant et je reste convaincu
que c'est à la base comprennent qu'on
crée vraiment sa chance ou pas alors
vous dites ce que j'ai essayé de faire
on ne le reverra plus il faut pas rêver
c'est à dire que vous pensiez qui aura
pas d'écurie au jour d'aujourd'hui c'est
un championnat constructeurs ouais donc
il ya une vraie
un vrai problème économique 1 pour
trouver sponsors il y aura certainement
une ou deux autres équipes qui vont être
dans l'embarras dans très peu de temps
et c'est un championnat constructeurs
donc qu'il y aura peut-être plus de 12
équipes n'aura peut-être plus que 7 8 9
ouais et des petites équipes comme ça
c'est impossible dans la mesure où les
sponsors vont aller quand même plutôt
bien les constructeurs faut quand même
savoir qu'une équipe ça c'est des
chiffres mais c'est important une équipe
4e au championnat c'est à dire comme
saubert est quand même une équipe qui
ressemble un peu faim qui ressemble un
peu la nôtre n'a eu n'a eu que 4,3 pour
cent de visibilité télévision l'année
dernière et 70 80 % sont répartis dans
les trois premiers au championnat donc
c'est très difficile d'aller séduire les
sponsors sans visibilité les demandes de
ce 200 250 millions sponsor numéro un ce
n'est même plus des lots non parce que
300 millions pourraient poser des
stickers sur la voiture faut être un
très bon vendeur donc pas facile au
final j'avais le sentiment de vous êtes
fait avoir toute cette affaire
j'ai le sentiment de d'habitude c'est
toujours je regrette jamais rien donc là
je commence a dit me dire quand même je
regrette un peu ce qui s'est passé de
notre côté j'aurai certainement
regretter de ne pas l'avoir fait je
trouve que il ya quand même une
impression moi j'ai l'impression que ça
arrange beaucoup de gens qui est plus
des équipes de f1 en france donc il
fallait en fin de compte quel était le
l'homme providentiel le plus apte 1 a en
fin de compte a montré l'échec c'était
moi et ça rend chez la victime
expiatoire
si c'était à refaire vous feriez quoi
pas pareil
j'étais guide russe est le premier
conclu
2 millions d'euros
je ferais exactement ce que ce que j'ai
dit au directeur général de peugeot deux
jours avant la signature elle ne fait
pas je ne fais plus parce que je lui dis
malheureusement je suis revenu sur la
parole parce que je lisais pas possible
cette sept mois de travail et comme quoi
il faut jamais quand on a une une
impression la haine même avec beaucoup
de pression derrière il faut pas y aller
faut pas forcer le destin forcer le
destin mais maintenant je vais faire
quoi
maintenant je vais partir en vacances
réfléchir à réfléchir à comment rebondir
d'une heure où d'une autre parce que
toute façon ces vies donc j'allais
revenir en formule 1 quand même c'est
pas impossible impossible mais bon mais
il ya dix ans déjà j'ai déjà eu deux
contacts mais c'est pas ça sert à rien
aujourd'hui je peux absolument pas me
remettre dans un truc sans avoir pris un
peu de repos merci à vous exprimer aussi
franchement merci beaucoup
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux